ja denn man hat ja eine negation school
nach da würde ich natürlich gerne wissen
wie läuft das ab was ich gerade sagen
mein israelischer man dass wir erst zu
deutschland kam musste er ein
integrationskurs machen sei es auch mit
viele andere migranten und in einem
unterricht hat man ihm beigebracht dass
man seine frau nicht ermorden darf auch
nicht die schwester ja das ist also
wirklich so eingebildet im
integrationskurs weil er manchen
teilnehmer überraschend oder es war für
mich überraschend als mein mann das
erzählt hat sich meine okay dann hat man
schon verstanden dass man diese menschen
wahrscheinlich da zu aufklären muss aber
jetzt zu sagen das ist sehr seriös war
nicht wirklich weil mein mann hat danach
wirklich mit mit seinem syrischen freund
darüber einfach mal diskutiert hat dann
den freund gefragt sag mal wenn deine
schwester jetzt mit einem deutschen mann
geht was machst du und dann hat er dazu
gefragt was heißt es geht kurz oder was
anderes 6 und dann hat mein mann einfach
hinfahren und deine schwester mal sex
hat mit jemanden und dann hat der freude
der syrischer freund gesagt dann bringen
sie
und er war also das war sein rat war ein
das war kein scherz es war kein scherz
und mein mann
stand einfach da und war total
schockiert
ja das weißt du daraus daraufhin das ist
zumindest einen kleinen teil der markt
klein sein aber einen kleinen teil
derjenigen die zu uns gekommen sind gibt
die man auf diesen umstand aufmerksam
machen muss dass man das eben nicht tun
darf
ja er hat nicht jahres nutzen es aber
nichts das mag für ihren mann ganz
seltsam geklungen haben aber es gibt
ganz offensichtlich einen teil
derjenigen die bei uns sind den man das
erklären muss im übrigen ist das uns ja
auch alles nicht in die wiege gelegt
wurde ich komme aus duisburg ich habe
ich hab in den 70er 80er jahren dort
auch dienst gemacht und deutschen
ehemännern erklären müssen dass man
seine frau nicht schlagen darf die der
festen überzeugung waren wieso oder
nicht das ist doch meine frau und das
war auch nicht so ist keine duisburg
spezialität sondern überall ich will nur
noch auf eine differenzierung hinweisen
weil sie gesagt alle reden nur über die
plans wir reden nur über den kriminellen
teil der knapp
700.000 familienmitglieder wo viele ganz
normal integriert sind die auch zu
diesem klar zu dieser großräumige
geworden aber eben nicht im kriminellen
milieu und deswegen auch
kleinkriminalität selbst und so über den
kriminellen teil dieser kurs ist ganz
wichtig dass bei der ganzen diskussion
dass wir klar legen dass wir gesetzt
haben und die gesetze muss man sich
halten und egal aus welcher kultur war
kommen das ist wenn man aus dem eigenen
land kommt den müssen an uns uns unsere
gesetze halten in unserem land haben und
natürlich kommen menschen in unser land
wir haben einen anderen hintergrund
haben eine andere kultur die haben eine
andere gesetzgebung und sie verstehen
weil ich geh jetz in ein lockeres land
ich meine muss jetzt auch verstehen es
kommt muslime in unserem land in ein
christliches abendland und sie sehen gar
nichts davon sie sehen gar nichts davon
ja sie sehen ich glaube ein christentum
sie sehen überhaupt keinen judentum aber
sie versuchen ihre also manche versuchen
das mit mit zu uns zu bringen weil wir
für alles offen sind und wer alles offen
ist es nicht ganz dicht das ist meine
aussage wir müssen auch unsere regeln
vermitteln wir müssen sie aber auch
vorleben ja sie haben vorhin die lehrer
erwähnt hier und ich muss schon sagen
dass ich manchmal das gefühl habe dass
die lehrer in deutschland ich es auch
ein bisschen leicht machen natürlich es
gibt nicht genug geld es gibt alles als
ja alles ist korrekt aber es gibt auch
schulen in deutschland in den großteil
90 prozent der kinder von einem
muslimischen hintergrund sind und dann
sagen die lehrer zum beispiel wir tun
den holocaust überhaupt nicht wir reden
und nicht über den holocaust weil das
dann zu problemen führen kann und jetzt
frage ich wenn wir diese kinder hier in
deutschland aufziehen wollen wenn diese
kinder dann auch wirklich deutsch sein
sollen müssen sie sich ja auch mit der
deutschen geschichte mal beschäftigen
sie haben im gewissen sinne haben sie
recht aber das problem ist nicht der
lehrer das problem ist das system warum
haben wir in berlin klassen in dem 24
kinder gehen die keine deutsche herkunft
haben und ein deutsches kind warum
verteilen wir diese kinder nicht auf
verschiedene klassen in ganz berlin wir
haben ein kostenloses nahverkehrsticket
und wir haben von vornherein diese
probleme nicht mehr der lehrer kann das
problem nicht lösen der soll's
bestimmten unterricht machen hat aber 24
gegner gingen wie soll der lehrer das
schaffen wenn das system nicht die
möglichkeit schafft dass der lehrer
bessere unterstützung hat der kann das
gar nicht machen und wir wollen ja nicht
den lehrer sozusagen an einem polizisten
an die seite stellen damit er das
überhaupt machen kann deswegen muss
dieses system sich mal überlegen wie
kann ich die probleme in dieser stadt
und auch irgend herausgeforderten
bezirken lösen warum steckt weil ich in
buckow in britz in rudow zwei schüler
pro klasse die aus einer kasse kommen wo
ist nur kinder mit migrationshintergrund
weil jetzt doch auch weltweit das kinder
fast immer im also neben zu hause zur
schule ich finde herr siegel chur sie
haben gerade eben ein ganz spannend satz
gesagt und zwar den habe ich mir auch
notiert wer für alles offen ist ist
nicht ganz dicht das würde ich gerne
noch einmal an herrn wendt spielen
diesen satz und fragen ob wir vielleicht
auch einfach härtere regeln brauchen und
jetzt kommt eine schachtel satz den ich
eigentlich nicht machen sondern aber den
mache ich jetzt ist die
migrationspolitik in letzten 30 jahren
gescheitert also dass die
integrationspolitik gescheitert ist
darüber muss man sich in vielen teilen
überhaupt nicht unterhalten sie ist
vielfach geglückt ja aber sie ist eben
auch vielfach gescheitert da wo ganze
stadtteile da sind die im grunde
genommen für deutsche
integrationspolitik fast verloren
gegangen sind so viele menschen sich
auch offen weigern können sich zu
integrieren und ganze gruppen da ist das
gescheitert und es hat viel integrations
romantik in den letzten jahrzehnten
gegeben wo einzelne geglückte fälle
hochgesetzt werden als wäre das
sozusagen die ihr glück für integration
in deutschland und nirgendwo verdrückt
wird dass integration vor allen dingen
auch eine bringschuld derjenigen ist die
zu uns gekommen sind es wird häufig der
eindruck vermittelt als der integration
vor allen dingen eine aufgabe unserer
gesellschaft und war da wo sie nicht
geklappt hat unsere gesellschaft versagt
denn wo immer aus aus migranten dann
kriminalität kommt ja heißt dass die
gesellschaft die deutsche gesellschaft
hat in ihrer integrationspolitik
versagen ist natürlich blanker unfug
wahl zur integration gehören immer zwei
und vor allen dingen ist es eine
bringschuld derjenigen die zu uns
gekommen sind erster punkt
nein ich glaube wir haben schon gute
regeln wir müssen sie nur durchsetzen
und auch anwenden wir können immer
wieder die gesetze verschärfen immer
wieder schärfere strafen machen und die
justizvollzugsanstalten vollpacken er
sie meinen gewissen umsetzen wir müssen
sie umsetzen und kommt leider wieder auf
mein heimatland nordrhein westfalen da
beginnt man jetzt gerade damit das
umzusetzen aber wir müssen eben
konsequent dranbleiben das wird nicht in
zwei jahren gehen und wir müssen da wo
es möglich ist
die leute wir haben die meisten von
denen wir sprechen den ganzen abend
haben wir bereits deutschen pass ich
bezweifle dass das richtig ist
weil der deutsche post gehört an das
ende eines integrationsprozesses nicht
an den anfang aber der zug ist längst
abgefahren aber da wo das nicht der fall
ist müssen bei der begehung von
straftaten und bei dem strafverfahren
auch aufenthaltsbeendende maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden das ist häufig leider
nicht der fall man kann sich manche
strafregister anschauen da fragt man
sich warum sind die menschen überhaupt
noch bei uns warum tun wir uns das
eigentlich an immer wieder
strafverfahren einzuleiten immer wieder
zu bestrafen und neben hat sagt jemand
du musst jetzt auch mal unser land
voller sex gibt kein land der welt das
sich so viele sternsinger aktion ist
also wird natürlich zu wenig abgeschoben
es ist ganz eindeutig aus britischen
rücksichtnahme obwohl sämtliche
rechtlichen voraussetzungen vorliegen
nicht der staat immer wieder zurück auch
aus angst vor protesten oder vorgängen
in den eigenen parteien das ist ganz
ganz klar ein straftäter jemand der ein
land kommt hat sich an regeln zu halten
das wurde mehrfach hier betont wenn die
regelverletzung zu regeln wird gibt der
rechtsstaat und man lässt das also ganz
offensichtlich in teilen gewähren und
ich möchte nur zu noch etwas anderes
sagen ein staat wird so wahrgenommen wie
er sich gibt und kassierte voraus ich
wieder keine wertung und keinen wunsch
es gibt männer kreis als rechtsextrem
ich will noch folgende sagen diese leute
kommen aus ländern in denen
nationalstolz vorhanden ist mich an
leute gefragt wie kommt es dass in ihrem
land die bundeskanzlerin merkel ich ist
die glaub ich bei meinen merkel 16 jahre
war sie unsere kreistagswahl so lange
war dass ich war viele jahre nicht in
deutschland wissen sie ich habe lange im
ausland fühlen usa gelebt die diesen
jahren aber gott sei dank so der punkt
ist natürlich der dass wenn eine bundes
kann unsere fahne in die ecke wirft so
im offenen widerwärtigen gefühl dass ich
andere was ist denn das für ein land
leider hat sie die fahnen widerwärtigen
ecke geworfen am abend der
bundestagswahl des jahres 2013 stand sie
zwar nun für ein gutes ergebnis ein das
einzige mal wo sie vor merkel die
stimmen bestimmen steigern konnte 56 da
hat die da gestanden sein kam der herr
gröhe als generalsekretär der christlich
demokratischen union deutschlands und
hat den kann erleben wollen auf den sieg
das ist ja weg kennt noch mit dem kopf
geschüttelt und ist zur seite gerannt
und hat sie in die ecke geschmissen eine
solche geste wird weder in frankreich
noch in großbritannien noch den usa auch
nur denkbar seien
auch hintergrund
stolze bürger der bundesrepublik zu
sagen dass es klar zu sagen ich auch
aber die durch den kurz unterbrechen
wenn ich musik der ein land hat auch
etwas mit respekt zu tun und ich finde
das ein bisschen an masten was ich
gerade gesagt er ein regal oder eine
kurzbahn wir haben über die
regierungschefin dieses landes
gesprochen und abwertend ja was ist das
für ein beispiel in der öffentlichkeit
wenn wir abwertend über regierungen
springen können sie natürlich
kritisieren all das was sie tun wir
müssen so zeitig mit einem 1 machen aber
wir sollten zumindest für den menschen
stehen die die gewählt wurde sind die
dahin werde ich nicht moment moment
vielleicht haben wir sie nicht gewählt
aber ich denke wir fordern von menschen
respekt ein die aus einem anderen land
kommen dann müssen wir als gute
vorbilder vorangehen wenn ein
regierungschef der eine von der
bevölkerung dieses landes gewählt wurde
in freien wahlen das nationale symbol
die fahne von sich weg wird ist diese
person nicht geeignet regierungsrat zu
übernahmen dann stelle ich fest dass ich
dies ganz klar kritisiert
was ist das denn jetzt nur für den
hintergrund wenn sie wieder besser also
es gibt es gibt hier einen hintergrund
warum man in deutschland sehr lange sie
einfach mit der deutschen fahne rum
marschiert hat und ja ich weiß ganz
genau und da hätte ich mich auch dazu
dass wir zu dieser geschichte stehen und
nie wieder nie wieder sagen das hat mich
freuen wenn heute in der ukraine
viele deutsche auch so denken würden ja
dass wir das nie wieder zu lassen was
wieder gesagt und ich nicht
einmal auf unser zehnmal der sendung
sind ja wir werden ja nicht wir sind im
thema wie verbinden sie das beides
zusammen helga vorerst also sie sagen
dass die kleinkriminalität auch da ist
bei frau merkel die fahne weggeworfen
hat ja weil der missachtung staatlicher
autorität ein staat der sich selbst
nicht achtet kann auch nicht mehr gab es
schon vor freuen er kann auch nicht
andere sprache über einen ganz konkreten
umstand und dafür könnte ihn auch viele
beispiele von zuvor nennen es gibt
einfach jedes volk finde ich für mich
ist meine fahne etwas schönes die
vereine meines landes verein gestartet
werden sie bestraft wenn sie die
anstecken israel dürfe nicht viel anders
sein das war ich noch nicht kenne dich
um die fahne was ich gesagt habe ich
bemerken es um die fahne wie ich mit der
fahne umgehe so steht zu dem start in
dem ich bin als gewählte vertreterin was
nicht ausreden so ging es eher wie sie
vorher gemerkt wir sehen
was meinen sie was ich nicht wusste sie
16 jahre alt ist ich war eigentlich
etwas geschafft was keiner mehr zu dem
lösungsansatz damit wollen wir auch weil
die sendung beenden und die damit
schuldigen ist ja wirklich gerne einen
dich antonia übergeben wir haben hier
viele präventionsmaßnahmen auch vor
allem von herrn sie gehört wie die
lösungsansätzen sein könnten wie würdest
du denn auch vielleicht blickt wiesen
israel passiert das sehen für
deutschland wie man es schafft dass die
nächste generation nicht mehr in den
klatschmedien eintritt also alles halb
israelin muss ich schon sagen in
deutschland sind die strukturen sehr
kompliziert alles in deutschland ist
kompliziert haben sie vorhin erwähnt die
polizei wenn was macht dann kann ist
aber nicht wegen diesem grund von justiz
und und stadt man sollte ein bisschen
lockerer sein in diesem land dass
erstens zweitens denke ich schon dass
man mir diese also man sollte mit diesen
leuten auch sprechen also und sie nicht
verachten und wenn wir wollen dass sie
deutsche sind sollen wir sie auch als
deutsche behandeln und das wäre mal für
mich wichtig
wir sind sie dafür würden sie nach etwas
ergänzen zudem ich glaube dass wenn wir
menschlich sind dann können wir überall
als menschen hingehen ich kann auch
überall hingehen ich kann zu jeder
religion gern ich gar nicht zu jedem
klar gehen ich muss ein gutes vorbild
sein ich muss authentisch sein und ich
muss das was ich sage auch leben das ist
mir wichtig ich bin christ und das ist
auch gut so ich glaube an gott und ich
kann jedem menschen in die augen schauen
das kann ich und ich glaube wir brauchen
eben diese vorbilder also spreche jetzt
nicht von ihr sondern überhaupt in
unserer bevölkerung wir brauchen
natürlich auch
gesetze die umgesetzt werden und es kann
nicht sein dass ein pädophiler
straftäter
mildere umstände bekommt wenn ein
steuerhinterzieher dafür jahre lang ins
gefängnis geht da müssen wir auch
authentisch zu sein und
ich glaube ja wir müssen alle ein
bisschen darüber nachdenken wie wir in
diesem land miteinander leben können und
das beste rausholen können und dinge die
wir in den nachrichten gehört haben von
clans und von anderen querdenker etwas
was ich muss man im keim ersticken und
zeigen wir haben hier regeln an sie
müssen uns der frage ich hier nach als
letzte frage an sie herr wendt wie kann
man das denn im keim ersticken also
zunächst mal ist manchmal ganz einfach
wir brauchen wir haben regeln in einer
freiheitlichen demokratie auch in einer
offenen gesellschaft an die muss man
sich halten und wer sich nicht daran
hält muss die sanktionen auch erfahren
dass der staat muss die regelsätze auch
durchsetzen und eins ist auch klar gute
bildung und gute sozialpolitik gute
familienpolitik erspart uns die arbeit
der polizei ersparen sie aber der
politik weil sie verhindert das
entstehen von kriminalität auch dafür
gibt es schon gute beispiele in baden
württemberg in nordrhein westfalen den
anderen ländern gibt es gute beispiele
wo justiz sozialarbeit und polizei
schulen ganz frische und
zusammenarbeiten und da wird das aus
verhindert das ist möglich aber man
braucht den staat der das macht man darf
es nicht outsourcen an private immer
wieder private gesellschaft die
rahmenbedingungen die rahmenbedingungen
müssten diejenigen die diese arbeit
machen und zwar nicht nur bei polizei
und justiz sondern auch in der
sozialarbeit müssen auch beruflich
langfristige perspektive und anständige
arbeitsbedingungen haben dann sind wir
auch motiviert und leisten gute arbeit
und dann vorhin der kriminalität nicht
nur kleinkriminalität und damit
herzlichen dank